Keshia chante Fiji Canada ready we're
again Toronto really have you been
please
I know everybody in this business has
been in Toronto you never know yeah well
shot long kiss goodnight there I've said
about six films in Toronto oh you're
just fancy you've shot every film what
have you not shot a lot of places but
Toronto's one of the familiar places yep
congratulations by the way the Raptors
are you upset are you hurt a little bit
are you I don't know do have another
team I was in Toronto the first year
after starting I was I was their first
celebrity fan Wow so I went to a lot of
games the first year because Isaiah was
general manager and my friends and I
know a lot of people associated with the
team so and in jackiebrown welcome bag
after bag you have been I mean a part of
Marvel Universe since the very beginning
do you give advice to these you know
young actors on how to last as long as
you have no no I think the only person
that had a long conversation with about
the Marvel Universe was Bri because we
were together and talking about it and
what she was getting into and how it was
gonna be for her and what what the
changes would be in you know we had a
good conversation but she's she's up to
the task
yes yes and obviously you're a cool cat
and people love gusta cat people online
I've been talking about I spin off with
you and goose the cat really yeah I'm
paid attention to that yeah are you
gonna write yeah yeah I have a social
presence but you know I don't
necessarily look at other people's
things that I do what I'm doing saying
and I'm gone yeah you post what you want
you project what you want to protect you
and you don't looking at what else yeah
okay I look at other people's stuff do I
follow a bunch of people uh uh anybody
interesting no no okay no one
interesting no one interesting so
spider-man far from home it's hard to
talk about it without giving away
spoilers mm-hmm but what I can say is it
was amazing
it was so enjoyable oh good watching you
in it I mean you really make everything
you say pretty much iconic like what's
it like at home what are you like at
home are you just like rambling
one-liners yeah yeah my whole life's a
t-shirt yeah no no no my daughter takes
some corny sometimes no she laughs at me
we have fun together
my wife's busy being an actress I'm
wondering why you not me and you know
but we have a good life through that
it's all right yeah yeah
is there a scene in this film that is
your favorite or was your favorite to
shoot I guess my favorite is mainly
because I hadn't hadn't really been
around a lot when Jake was doing what
Jake was doing we had our encounters but
I didn't really know exactly what was
happening with Mysterio so when I saw
the film was kind of like oh oh this is
what happened and I guess now that we've
lost Tony Stark we need somebody else to
deliver interesting speeches so yeah he
kills it yeah you've basically been in
every film I mean it's there you really
you've had so many iconic roles you've
done so much great work is there
anything else that's just on your list
of things you want to do me as an actor
yeah it's like any type of role or Phil
I mean film acting is not like the
theatre where you know you reach a
certain age or you think you've
developed enough as an actor to play
Hamlet and already third or any of that
stuff you just kind of read stories and
hope that there's an interesting and fun
story that you can be a part of and
there's a character in there that you
haven't played that allows you to grow
some way or to impact the story and a
memorable and and wonderful kind of way
and then you want to be a part of it so
I just look forward to that the the
discovery of you know that story of the
discovery of that character see what
happens
you